si on arrive à le voir les cogneurs
ben oui je crois que ce sampler n'est
pas du tout usurpée tout le monde a vu
civique détient comédien hors pair je
crois me choque c'est que les tours de
cluses et je suis quand même sur scène
un tassement lombaires le déplacement de
vertèbre contre le mur aussi parce que
moi sur scène givet frank o coillot n'a
peur de rien donc je je je me jette à 30
ans à cracher sur le lourd une fois ça
arrive et la tête en premier la tasse
vos lombaires en bleu oui mais bon faut
c'est c'est tellement un moment de
bonheur qu'ont donc voilà c'est pas le
ton à sion convient a découvert les
joies de la comédie l'actorat je dirais
même au delà de la comédie et de puis
voilà quoi vous êtes invités par votre
nouveau métier
voilà ça doit vous avez d'autres
propositions depuis sept ans cours de
théâtre deux pièces normalement mais
c'est que des projets
elle
ce que je voulais rien nos amis et
spectateurs c'est que la presse et
hulene n'est pas la tige pour le moment
et qui peuvent aller voir donc on tire
bien sûr les lapins au théâtre fontaine
de gerpinnes teurs ses excellents je
vous conseille d'y aller parce que là
vous allez vraiment vous imprégnez vous
de de cet acte aura qui désormais
constitue le coeur de votre vie steevy
rythme doit enlever votre casquette
parce que j'ai peur d'un truc c est
apple faisait pas non sérieux en
changeant de couleur de cheveux vous
avez pas peur d'eux a pris un gros
risque pour votre carrière
non nous allons prendre j'espère pas que
damien je sais pas je sais pas je sais
pas non moi j'aime bien comme ça écouter
les gens vont s'y faire c'est très bien
vous trouvez ça bien sonia oui bon ça me
fait drôle d'être à côté d'elle parce
que ça fait tellement d'années que je
faisais à regarde à la télévision en
fait j'ai un grand fan de ce soleil
ouais bien non mais sérieusement
pourquoi que je vais abandonner le jaune
pour vos cheveux platine jeu sommes là
c'est qu'est ce qui s'est passé ça s'est
passé comme l'était c'était un mardi ou
fois non pas que peut-être je me
rappelle pas mais déjà pour mes cheveux
c'est pas bon on peut pas faire des
colorations sur déclaration tout le
temps j'ai pas envie de me retrouver
chauve et à faire des implants et les
sourcils c'est pas naturel ceci si mais
tout est naturel sur la possible
naissance il commet jamais vu ça à moi
bah regret cependant extrêmement bien
dessinée vous savez il faut sortir en
dehors du baron moore
tu vas je dire je ferme les yeux je mets
cette musique cher monsieur barreau
excusez moi
non j'ai changé de couleur de cheveux
pourquoi vous en aviez marre des bleus
avait marre des blagues sur les blondes
non parce que comme on reconnaît une
vraie blonde c'est une brune décolorés
qu'on fait un bon alors pourquoi est ce
que les blondes ont un boulot ici
pourquoi parce qu'il existe aussi des
blonds c'est pour faire oublier le stv
du là c'est bon ça mais dites moi moi ah
non mais on va pas parler de macau
bouche voilà c'est les revenus pour sa
puissance et sa couleur du jeu bougez
pas jardin vous êtes prêt à quoi pour
faire oublier leur à rien parce que je
suis très fier d'avoir fait le loft et
son le loft n'en serait pas là
aujourd'hui
ouais donc voilà je suis très
reconnaissant envers vous êtes prêt à
renoncer aux fautes de français par
exemple il faut faire avec le temps fait
des progrès alors maintenant en plus du
relais a tout essayé ou fait des disques
non j'ai enfin je fais des disques pour
enfants
oui ces appels et comptines 2stv 23
petites comptines sur les animaux et la
nature présenté l'une après l'autre avec
beaucoup de tendresse pecquery et
d'humour par stevie un album très joyeux
à la fois drôle et émouvant
c'est chez sony music voilà alors ce
qu'il faut dire à nos amis
téléspectateurs c'est qu'avant chaque
petite comptine ya une petite racontines
et la petite raconte insee steevy qui
présente la petite comptine
c'est magnifique vous ne m'en voudrez
pas si vite j'ai choisi la carotte mais
il n'ya pas que les lapins qui mangent
des carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffolent
le jour des épluchures de carotte c'est
si bon qu'il a recentré le rock
dans le piège de la carte ce disque de
style y est autobiographique de tous les
lapins qui mangent des carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffole le
jour des épluchures de carotte c'est si
bon bilan chanterelle rock dans les
vêtements je pensais que j'avais fait ça
pour faire un peu de pognon et tout et
j'ai compris en l'écoutant que c'était
parfaitement autobiographique c'est de
vous dans ma part épaté le gatti cochon
qui mangent des clouds avec vous voici
j'ai fait ce produit c'est que je suis
très attaché à cette tradition qui se
perd malheureusement les parents
raconter des histoires à leurs enfants
avant de s'endormir jours les maisons
mais c'est vrai nom était le véritable
là dessus c'est que en plus ça permet
aux enfants de enfin ça développe leur
côté créatif parce que les imaginez vous
avez des idées mal placées
donc voilà donc ça c'est la racontines
qui vient avant la cantine
et puis après évidemment après il ya la
comptine 2stv effet c'est le ch'tri
carottes
pour lui le jour des peluches aux
alors là
d
mais il n'ya pas que les lapins qui
mangent des carottes
le petit cochon lui aussi en raffolent
les vieilles dans la rue c'est sûr donc
ça s'appelle les comptines 2stv par
stevie voilà aura maintenant tester un
petit peu comme chez laurent ruquier
d'ailleurs en matant tester vos qualités
de comédien stv ah ouais